let's talk about Loop Diuretics just as
their name says they work on the loop of
Henley within that nefron and they
increase urinary output how they do this
is they inhibit the sodium potassium
chloride co-transporter protein and this
affects sodium reabsorption their names
tend to in in mid or n like froide they
are used for fluid volume overload which
is found in heart failure hypertension
AES pulmonary edema nursing
responsibilities include monitoring
fluid status through blood pressure
weight eyes and nose and electrolytes
side effects include hypocam remember
this this is huge if they're on dig it
could cause dexin toxicity it can lower
calcium levels lower sodium levels watch
out if they're taking Lithium which
could cause lithium toxicity it can also
cause oo toxicity give slowly IV
especially forosamine educate the
patient about signs and symptoms of
dehydration potassium rich foods daily
weights and changing positions slowly
due to orthostatic hypotension